I interviewed your buddy Ryan Reynolds
and he said there probably won't be
another standalone Deadpool movie and
then he stopped and he said I continue
to do full-court press for Hugh Jackman
to to come back to no avail is it nice
yeah God God knows he's just been
failing constantly
have we seen the last of Wolverine
Wolverine he'll be back
someone's gonna ply him I don't know not
you though no but Ryan is
he's relentless he keeps coming back to
me in all these ways shaving form it and
I said well you know I just don't think
the world really wants to see Deadpool
with Wolverine they I mean maybe a cameo
from Deadpool I just think it runs over
it for Deadpool I don't know his
argument then was that he thought he'd
give a little boost to your career
really by putting you in a movie
it's nice concerned about a bond got it
you know that term dag I mentioned the
dag is a goofball would you say goofball
an American right you would say a goof
you're such a dag Ryan don't scratch up
the timeline look eventually you're
gonna hang up the clause and it's gonna
make a lot of people very sad huh one
day your old pal Wade's gonna ask you to
get back in the saddle again when he
does say yes hey everybody it's Charlie
Hugh Jackman Ryan Reynolds dropping a
couple of Deadpool Wolverine bombs that
we have to break down they confirm a
couple really big things during this
even though it seems like they're just
having fun so I'll explain what's going
on there's a new round of that game
giveaway for a Red Dead Redemption or
the spider-man ps4 game all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a Marvel related comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this mostly this is about Hugh Jackman
talking about returning as Wolverine in
some form or another like he's shooting
down some ideas but he's saying yes to a
couple other things but it's also about
Ryan Reynolds confirming that they're
probably not going to do any more solo
Deadpool movies which just blows my mind
but it does kind of fit with what
everyone at Disney everyone at Fox Ryan
Reynolds Kevin Feige had been saying for
the past few months while the Fox Disney
deal slowly closes and they get all
those x-men and Fantastic Four character
back so let's unpack all this number 5
hugh jackman confirms that there
probably will be a Wolverine cameo in an
upcoming Deadpool movie right now just
you know based on what Ryan Reynolds
says when he says Deadpool movie he's
just talking about a movie that Deadpool
is headlining not necessarily a Deadpool
solo movie because it sounds like what
Ryan Reynolds is meaning when he says
there won't be another Deadpool solo
movie is is it Deadpool will only appear
in team-up movies from here on out which
is good and bad for a lot of reasons for
that movie right now that's on the
docket is Drew Goddard x-force so
obviously that's a team-up movie which
is currently Fox's last x-men movie that
it's working on before the Fox Disney
deal closes quick timeline right now
Dark Phoenix and New Mutants are already
pretty much done they're just polishing
them a little bit they'll release them
next year
but they'll be released by Disney so
it'll be Fox movies released by Disney
so it's sort of an in-between period
normally x-force would be like a full
Disney Kevin Feige movie but because Fox
put that into development its site all
the contracts with the actors the
writers directors it sounds like they're
just gonna let them make that movie
Kevin Feige will probably just take a
producer credit and oversee it just to
make sure they don't run into any
problems like you're great you're in
your own universe you're doing your own
thing report back to me for your next
assignment when you're done with this
because any future movie that Ryan
Reynolds wants to do as Deadpool after
x-force he will have to pitch to Kevin
Feige first a lot of people have been
asking about Deadpool showing up in an
Avengers film the interesting thing is
is that the Disney CEO has been
mentioning that more than anyone else
more than Kevin Feige like oh yeah
Deadpool in the Avengers that would be
great and if the CEO of Disney Bob Iger
really likes an idea usually down the
road you see someone try to make that
work 3 Hugh Jackman is having a lot of
fun with Ryan Reynolds during this
interview like when he says the world is
over Deadpool and Wolverine together and
nobody wants that like he gives this
deadpan delivery like he's totally
serious but he's really joking because
he knows that everyone wants to see
Wolverine and Deadpool team-up the real
reason why you did not see him cameo
during Deadpool 2 is mostly just a
practical scheduling thing because of
course Ryan Reynolds tried to get him to
cameo he was busy with pre-production on
the front runner movie
that they released a little while ago
where he plays this political candidate
running for office that was all
happening while they were doing
principal photography for Deadpool to
last summer so if you have a bit
following Hugh Jackman on social media
most of the early part of 2018 this year
when they were polishing Deadpool -
doing reshoots and all that stuff when
you would normally have a couple days to
slip Hugh Jackman in for a Wolverine or
a Hugh Jackman meta cameo Hugh Jackman
was running all over the world promoting
the greatest showman his other big movie
that they released December in 2017 it
was this really strange box-office
behavior for that greatest showman movie
so Fox kept sending him all over the
world promoting the film for months so
physically he just wasn't able to spend
the time to do with Deadpool cameo that
is why he saw Ryan Reynolds lean so hard
on those Wolverine Logan jokes at the
beginning of Deadpool - like the little
music box
the verbal joke about how he was gonna
top Wolverines ending you kill yourself
I'm gonna do it way better than you did
Wolverine Wolverine first he rides my
coattails with the army then the hairy
[ __ ] ups the ante by dying dick
we also got that post credit scene from
the extended edition where he talks a
little bit about hate your friend Ryan
Reynolds is gonna ask you to cameo in a
movie make sure you say yes mostly all
in response to Hugh Jackman just being
too busy to actually cameo in Deadpool 2
like we're gonna try this again when we
do another Deadpool movie that next
movie is going to be x-force - a lot of
you will remember Hugh Jackman has
previously said that he'd love to come
back as Wolverine on the condition that
it be for a big Avengers MCU movie this
is a clip of him referencing that it's
interesting because for the whole 17
years I kept thinking it had to be so
great like I would love to see you know
particularly Iron Man or the Hulk and
and Wolverine together every time I saw
an Avengers movie I could just see
Wolverine in the middle of him like
punching him all in the head I thought
but it was like oh well that's not gonna
happen and it was just when I first saw
that headline it was just a possibility
of it and who knows what's gonna happen
I was like that's actually from an
interview about a year ago when they had
first started talking about the Fox the
Disney deal was still pretty early but
it seems like he's still pretty adamant
or adamantium if you want to make
Wolverine puns that he won't headline
another big film as Wolverine just
something smaller which is where all
this cameo talk is coming from all of
the current interviews that he's been
doing especially this interview here is
that when you see Wolverine with the
Avengers as a main character in a big
film as a huge part of the story it'll
be another character like a younger
actor will be recast because the
rebooting the universe and even though
we do have Laura
x-23 she's still way too young to
completely take the mantle and because
this is such a big deal
Disney getting all the x-men characters
back you're not gonna undercut that by
not doing Wolverine at all he might just
wait a little while to introduce him so
number one pretty easy slam dunk the
early pitch for actual Hugh Jackman
appearing in future films right now is
just an X force as a joke because
Deadpool is so meta the timeline doesn't
have to make sense
Logan was such a beautiful film and such
a great bookend for the character in the
Fox Marvel films that if you're gonna
have them appear in present day it won't
make sense without that full reboot of
the x-men and Fantastic Four characters
and that's gonna take a little while
before they're ready for that so early
prediction just in the name of sanity
Hugh Jackman cameos and x-force they
turn it into a big joke everybody loves
it and it doesn't cause any continuity
problems and doesn't undercut the
emotional ending that he got in Logan
then after Kevin Feige reboots the x-men
completely with new actors a ways down
the road you reintroduce a new version
of Wolverine that they've recast in an
Avengers movie spider-man Civil War
style we're getting into multiverse
stories during phase four then really
big moment eight to ten years down the
road when they're ready for like another
big infinity war level event they do
Avengers secret Wars you have a bunch of
different realities colliding with each
other so you have alternate universe
versions of characters that can be
on-screen together but you also use it
to bring back Hugh
jackman is an alternate universe old man
Logan from his real x-men timeline
there's a whole bunch of trailers coming
in the next week I know everybody's
waiting for Avengers 4 trailer leave
your requests in the comments below
congratulations pepino cucumber you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel click here to
rewatch that once upon a Deadpool
Christmas trailer and click here to
learn all about the venom sequel thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome and Happy Thanksgiving
[Music]